no I was 39 when they offered me that
job and I had been share of the
department went up between when I was 20
when I was 32 to 35 so I was a very
young chair so because of that people
offered me you know what would be asked
me with was the interesting dear the
college was interested in this and now
and finally offered me a job is so huge
him against the that's the largest
unrestricted academic budget in the
university was each other so huge it was
hard to turn down the sense that is you
know I knew it would she fundamentally
changed my life I often tell people they
the two most important decisions I made
in my life that didn't involve women one
was taking that job which was absolutely
the right thing to do reasons i can tell
you and the second was getting out of
the job which is also the right thing to
do for me to turn what I buy for both of
those well it opened doors to me it just
you know it gave me a view of the world
they never would have had no I learned
things about the University and about
the outside world and I wouldn't even
know I would never have known about
budgets and higher level administration
and trustees and his name that I never
would have learned if I had stayed in a
professor which is a very provincial
life so that's why it changed my life
you know because of that I was on his
fifth board because of that I'm on the
brown board because of that one aboard a
couple foundations or have been I am so
if you really change my life that way
and just expanded me in ways that I
wouldn't have been expanding it also it
also pushed my skills you know pushed my
people skills of which my budget skills
push my time management skills you know
there was an enormous job just an
enormous job on the other hand they
suffer so that that's the best a Y and
Chamberlain getting into a getting out
of it I often tell people you know at
that point I start getting on short list
for presidencies you know and if I stay
in the job that that was a route those
open today and I often say that if I'd
six or seven lives to live I mean I was
very conscious when I was thinking about
this one I was like 43 is oh if I had
six or seven lives to live i would spend
12 as a college president but I don't
have six or seven I only have one life
to live and I'd much rather spend
teaching a research and with my wife and
the job would have affected all three of
them especially it would affect my
relationship my wife nice man we're very
close we spend a lot of time together
with close friends you know of course
lovers and it would have been a
different relationship if I was running
two dinners every night with the nothing
nation I wouldn't had the time time that
she wanted needed tell you so from a
faculty point of view there was there's
no conflict no division you know it's
you come in here is the system professor
you'll walk into the classroom and in
your classroom you've got undergraduates
some of the general studies some of them
ecology and you're paid to teach both of
them and then you go into another
classroom you teach graduate students so
your job is there is to do research and
to do some administration help out and
to teach these three different groups of
students and there's no conflict now the
extent they were conflicts it had to do
with the way the university structured
budgeted you know so if you're at
Harvard Austin Sciences are one unit and
the college dean is really not an
important position and an enum Arts and
Sciences is sort of seen as the
important college game right what we're
here because that crazy history whether
with the budget used to grow the
Graduate being you have you had this
artificial separation and you still have
some alums who think you who think oh
well you know what would the arts and
science budget look like it what would
the college budget Leo the college
budget should just be by itself doesn't
make any sense there's you know
you can't have a college budget by
itself now if you want to say more of it
I mean what do you do with my salary now
you can make the college look like it's
terribly in debt or is a big money make
that depending on whether you tribute 0
my salary or n % of myself yeah I'm on
leave the semester doing research so
over maybe I should pay nothing towards
the calculated outfitter on the other my
lab is filled with undergraduate side
it's an artificial distinction that our
budget system has encouraged